good morning Hank it's Thursday June
19th and today's video comes to you in
3.5 parts because I'm tired of making 4
part videos part 1 is going to be an
apology to Toby and Toby ins part 2 is
going to be a pug for brother a 2.0
resident mathematician and future state
representative Daniel Biss part 3 is
going to be 60 seconds with the 14th
century in part 3.5 is gonna be asked
not what nerdfighteria can do for me ask
what I can do for nerdfighteria that was
a big breath part one Hank in your last
video you proposed that the opposite of
nerdfighter Lee was Toby and Hank I hate
to point this out but I think that might
have been a mistake first we started
receiving comments from Toby's who are
like hey my name is Toby and I'm a
nerdfighter and um why did you just do
that to my name
then we got three emails from people
whose last name is actually Toby n' and
then the straw that broke the camel's
back came when several anthropology
nerdfighters pointed out that we were in
fact insulting the 22 remaining
residents of the island of toby in the
south pacific who by the way speak an
extremely endangered language called
toby in' in fact the central reason that
there are so few people on the island of
toby is that the island of toby is
shrinking due to rising sea levels I
don't think we need to add to these
people's troubles by making their ethnic
identity synonymous with lameness so
Hank to apologize to Toby's and Toby uns
throughout the world I am proposing that
we remove toby in' from the nerdfighter
vocabulary and replace it with the word
Decepticon e'en which has kind of a nice
draconian ring to it you know part two
Hank as you know Brotherhood 2.0
resident mathematician Daniel Biss was
one of the very first nerdfighters and
you also know that he's running for
State Representative and you also know
that his wife is pregnant but here's
something you don't know his wife isn't
pregnant anymore because he had a baby
Elian austin Biss and now i shall do my
seated in my chair happy dance yay
Daniel now Hank I know that we were all
rooting for Daniel and Karen to name
their baby John Hank bubbles the nerd
fighting baby bits but you have to admit
that Elliott is also a good name so
anyway this is probably the last time
I'm ever going to talk about politics on
this channel but I really do believe in
Daniels candidacy and also I believe
that it would be very funny if Hank went
to the Sex in the City movie dressed as
Carrie Bradshaw please consider making a
donation to Daniel via act blue over
there or possibly over there and welcome
to the world Elliott part three sixty
Seconds with the 14th century Hank I was
inspired by a post over at my friend
Lindsay's blog to wonder what I would
say to the people of the 14th century if
they could watch a video that I made
that could only be 60 seconds long okay
60 seconds with the 14th century and go
hi John Greene here from the distant
future I know these make me look weird
but they help me to see better the
plague is spread by rats you should try
to kill them also the plague itself is
like a little miniature animal it gets
inside of your body and it pounds you I
know this sounds crazy but if you eat
the right amount of the fungus
Penicillium you can kill the plague
inside of you generally to prevent the
spread of these invisible monsters you
want to wash your hands and body a lot
with water and soap also reaches don't
work new subjects science the earth is
round the Sun is at the center of the
solar system the speed of light is
invariant the moon is not made of cheese
it's made of rock it turns out the
question of how many angels you can fit
on the head of a pin isn't very
interesting and if you put a cat inside
of a box with poison and you close the
box the cat is both alive and dead until
such a time as you open the box next the
future course of history if you don't
live in Europe or indeed if you don't
know what the word Europe means you're
about to be in big trouble listen
closely peoples of non Europe if you see
a dude who looks like me kill him
dftba people of the 14th century part
3.5 ask not what nerdfighteria can do
for me ask what I can do for
nerdfighteria hank in the last few weeks
we have been asking a lot of the
nerdfighters give money to daniel biss
send us your tetris pieces we want your
t-shirt ideas make me a collaboratively
written novel so nerdfighters let me ask
what can I do for you you want me to do
jumping jacks make some pudding recited
Edna st. Vincent Millay poem shirtless
let me know what I can do for
in comments and I'll do ten of those
things in a video I film this weekend